[Musique]
sébastien bovet michel si roger bonsoir
avec moi pour finir la saison de ce ce
panel ce domaine c'est ma dernière je
n'avais pas de pale ale demain on
présente une entrevue christine
st-pierre et panels américain et demain
sur ce qui se passe aux etats unis bon
pont pierre laporte
je commence avec vous c'est bastien non
on veut créer le ministre d'abord qui
dit le rapport sur l'état du pont il
l'avait pas vu jusqu'à la veille de
diers donc il ya deux jours on écoute
c'est certainement une inacceptable que
dans la chaîne de commandement
ce rapport aurait été déposée dévoilé à
certaines et au mois d'avril que le
cabinet politique moi même n'ayons pas
été informés
pour comprendre une chose je savais
qu'il y avait une consolidation
réparation de certaines substances l'an
passé nous avions une quarantaine de
suspendre consolidés d'ici la fin de
l'été mais il est console est
inconcevable que je n'ai pas été formé
que ce rapport les jeux rassurer les
gens qui nous écoutent ce soir le pont
pierre-laporte et sécuritaire
quand les ingénieurs était sorti début
mai en conférence de presse qu'ils sont
en négo difficiles avec le gouvernement
disant on joue avec la sécurité des gens
le pont pierre laporte est passé côté
que c'était le lendemain le mtq était
sorti indemne on n'y a rien qui est qui
qui tout va bien or ce c'est le 5 mai
que le ministère soit le 21 avril on
dépose sébastien ce rapport là comment
ça se fait que c'est perdu
ce que je comprends c'était peut-être
une chicane à l'intérieur du ministère
des transports entre la direction
régionale puis les gens qui font les
inspections des structures et cette
chicane a peut-être fait en sorte que le
rapport s'est perdue où il est pas
remonter assez rapidement au cabinet du
ministre en fait il ya deux questions la
première question c'est le pont pierre
laporte et ils sécuritaire la réponse du
gouvernement c'est dire oui
je peux pas croire qu'ils diraient autre
chose que la vérité sur la sécurité du
pont pierre laporte en principe il
éxécuté la deuxième question c'est
qu'est ce qui se passe au ministère des
transports pour que ce rapport là ne
remonte pas à la surface
il ya des sous ministres il ya des
ministres qui vont vous dire parfois
leurs sous ministre a redit leur disent
vous avez pas besoin de savoir ce genre
de choses là bas je m'excuse mais misera
des transports doit savoir ce qui se
passe avec un des points les plus
importants au québec avec 125 mille le
véhicule chaque jour et ça ça s'est pas
fait et peut-être que ce rapport là est
exagéré on n'en sait rien mais il est
quand même un peu alarmiste quinté c'est
pas juste de dire il ne dit pas que le
pont va tomber mais dit que un
détachement de câbles efforts possibles
une réaction en cascade pourrait être
possible ou si alors que les ministères
sorte ou non sébastien un mot avant de
passer la parole à wisches
la question qu'on peut se poser c'est
est ce que le ministre bonnardel aurait
rendu public ce rapport là s'il avait eu
il ya quelques semaines où il aurait
gardé pour lui il faut faire preuve de
transparence il faut dire les choses
telles qu'elles sont les il est obligé
de patiner un peu puis de faire du
rattrapage mais la structure en principe
va pas s'écrouler en même temps
rappelez-vous des viaducs au québec à
une certaine époque viaduc de la
concorde via dire que du souvenir qui
s'est effondré la commission johnson à
l'époque avait recommandé l'inspection
de tous les viaducs au québec on s'était
aperçu que il y en avait plusieurs qui
manqué d'amour et qui ont été détruits
par neuf et donc
le mtq a pas besoin historique très
reluisant ça peut-être changé depuis
quelques années mais à preuve jusqu'à
preuve du contraire faut leur faire faut
la faire contre non bien sûr puis michel
sait c'est quand même étonnant qu'ils
aient pas eu en bonne et due forme avec
graf et qu'elle n'a plus aujourd'hui
baguette pour présenter les choses du
minet s du sous ministre à côté
conférence de presse voici vous avez
entendu ceci cela la télé voici les
faits voici l'échéancier voici le c'est
un peu une entrevue par la porte arrière
un bain extrait ça fait désordre michel
non
beaucoup désordre qui comment voulez
vous que les citoyens se sentent à
l'aise qu'ils se sentent en sécurité
même si je ne doute pas celle
là dessus mais qu'un touche les
ministres ou va dire c'est gelé pour une
rapport j'aurais dû l'avoir qui cache
ses vers l'acquis dans la structure du
ministère des traces en croit qu'il ya
des choses qui ont pas besoin de monter
au bureau du ministre
il ya effectivement ce rapport retraite
qui est exact et je ne sais pas je
prends le génial que ça mais il ya des
choses qui sont troublants y compris le
fait que les cartes pourraient lâcher
les uns près des autres
cyril alors il faut rassurer les gens et
jeudi avec des forts
avec des faits parce que là et qu'est ce
que vous voulez les gens peuvent ne pas
avoir confiance et on peut les
comprendre
il ya un contexte de négociation avec
les ingénieurs aussi bien françois
legault aujourd'hui lille c'est parce
qu'il a commencé pour commenter le
rapport en disant faut comprendre qu'il
ya une négociation qui est difficile
avec les ingénieurs il faut aussi
comprendre que les ingénieurs ils ont
des responsabilités et puis produirait
pas enfin on l'espère rapport alarmiste
ou inquiétant pour une simple raison de
négociation de leur convention
collective recettes à ce qu'ils fassent
leur travail de façon rigoureuse
professionnelle ou 6 et qui soumettent
leurs rapports qu'ils auraient soumis
peu importe qui est négocié a pas de
négoce est ce que la négo vient vraiment
teinter le rapport probablement pas est
ce que la négo bien faire en sorte que
le rapport sortent comme ça on peut se
poser la question peut-être mais comme
vous dites siglé c'est pas le climat de
nego qui a fait créer un ingénieur
à cause du temps oui c'est ça le fond
durera pas alors le ministère oblige
troubles oui le trouble à pétrus et
l'ingénieur responsable du pont pierre
laporte le port sûr à part ça c'est fait
c'est fait rigueur
d'une chose on peut dire en
2010 pour chaque tir a pas que ça je
suis juste un gros lot mais bon mais
l'ingénieur responsable du pôle dupont
n'a pas reçu ceci est compressé et pour
parler à marie pierre l'ingénieur celui
qu'on voyait pas mais qu'est que marie
pier a rencontré plusieurs fois
il ya une crainte réelle ce pas vexer
juste les négos john que le monsieur qui
a paris on craindrait est elle exagérée
peut-être est ce que le ministère
devrait demander un autre avis externes
heures c'est ce que je comprends qu'ils
vont faire peut-être mais qu'on nous
expose tout ça faisait quand on parle
d'un pont pour tout mettre sur la table
mais n'était notée la version monsieur
bonnardel il donne presque raison à cet
ingénieur lanceur dallas d'alert parce
qu'il dit on va les remplacer les
suspentes au gour le plan c'était 15 ans
mais je veux accélérer les quinze années
donc c'est comme s'il dit pour faire ça
plus vite que ce qui était prévu bon
très bien fin de session ottawa la
semaine prochaine mais je veux d'abord
commencé sur on parlait de ça faisait
désordre le fait qu'ils aient pu en fait
c'est moi qui ai dit ça je pouvais
mettre des mots dans la bouche qui a pas
eu de conférence de presse précise
factuel dessinée avec des graphiques les
passeports c'est un peu la même chose a
l'impression que ottawa et on a
l'impression ottawa est débordé et que
ça laisse l'impression que leur
administration
est
débordé alors que les abstentions des
provinces qui peuvent critiquer par
ailleurs là ils ont ils disent nous on
préfère mieux michel c les passes par
lens avant le ca vaut rester comme une
tâche
ou écouter c'est quand même assez
extraordinaire dont on sort d'une
pandémie banc avec elle des gens pouvait
pas voyager donc des passeports sont
tombés chez nous on peut voyager est-ce
que c'est pas beaucoup d'imagination
pour comprendre que beaucoup de gens qui
vont vouloir faire un passeport nom est
où là et on peut faire la liste de
toutes sortes de choses si on peut faire
un chapeau sur tout ce qui sort du
bureau fédéral cet incident on prie
madame prennan qui dit hannon avons de
nouvelles mesures tout était correct
dans le budget ces deux gouvernements
qui est sur le pilote automatique et qui
ne boit pas ne semble pas voir là où il
ya besoin d'intervenir là où il ya
quelque chose qui va pas
normal déjà pour avoir un canada et il y
à toutes sortes d'autres exemples de ça
les diplomates qu'ils vont à la basse et
de russie j'allais vous en
mais restons sur un an oui c'est ça des
exemples où je vous parle après les
sorties de sébastien la sphère des
passeports bien sûr que la demande a
augmenté de considérer on comprend ça
mais je comprends pas c'est qu'on se
soit pas peut-être davantage préparée en
amont
et puis le gouvernement fédéral alan
gold a admis aussi qu'ils n'avaient pas
vu venir on présume qu'ils auraient dû
veut le voir venir ça tombait sous le
sens que les gens voudraient voyager une
fois que les mesures sanitaires allait
tomber comme si je suis passionné mais
c'est comme si le gouvernement de justin
trudeau et comme conforté dans sa survie
depuis l'entente avec le npd et puis que
plutôt que d'être un gouvernement
minoritaire
susceptibles de tomber à tout moment
même si le contexte politique ferait en
sorte qu'ils seraient pas si simon a six
ans mais ça les a comme confortés dans
leur leur survie pour les prochaines
années et c'est très terre à terre ce
genre de service là on certain à ce que
ça fonctionne quand on a besoin du
gouvernement lorsque si ça fonctionne
pas pu les scènes qu'on voit des gens
qui comme 48 heures pour obtenir l'heure
transports ont juste pas leur place je
vous amène une autre hypothèse que celle
là
il y a le fait que depuis plusieurs
années tout est concentré au bureau du
premier ministre
encore plus que jamais alors qu'il avait
dit qu'il ne le ferait pas ce sera un
peu le fait avant lui il ya une
concentration comme si la machine
administrative
et était avait perdu le sens de
l'initiative
parce qu'ils attendent lors de politique
je pense si l'ancien greffier michel c
est monsieur tellier qui le dit
monsieur trudeau est en train de
paralyser la machine de ce pays là parce
que il veut décider de tout michel
we les fonctionnaires ont peur de se
faire rabrouer s'ils prennent des
initiatives
ce qui fait qu'à un moment donné c'est
encore la priorité du pilote automatique
mais il ya une chose qui est importante
sébastien ya fait allusion ils ont
maintenant aucune raison de penser que
le goût l'odorat pourrait tomber mais
n'ont aucune raison on sait pas ce que
le premier ministre de faire
au canada il ya là dernier sera très
libre à quatrième mandat wilfred
et il est important pour la machine pour
le gouvernement pour ses députés d'avoir
une petite idée doudou le premier
ministre veut aller et de ce qu'il veut
faire et tant qu'on est dans cette
espèce de flou artistique de jeu par pas
mais je pense que si je reste 106 a des
effets sur la machine et ce à des effets
sur les ministres mesdames funèbres
aujourd'hui annonce un discours
important nous ont tous passé le massage
petit corps important toronto joe torre
est arrivé par disque offert son aide
sur l'inflation si ce qu'avait dans le
budget ça va bien merci bonsoir
ya quelque chose qui va pas et c'est
dans toutes sortes de dossiers des fois
beaucoup plus petit que madame plus là
nous allons étaient des diplomates mais
on dirait qu'il restait de blocage
j'avais l'impression qu'ils sont même
pas grave de gérer les passeports est ce
qu'ils sont capables de gérer de façon
générale c'est un exemple les passeports
très terre à terre je fais en sorte
qu'on puisse poser des questions sur la
façon dont ils gèrent leurs ce que je
voulais savoir aujourd'hui je n'ai pas
trouvé michel vous lisez encore plus que
moi la presse internationale est ce que
dans les pays de l' ocde par exemple qui
réussit ont ouvert leurs frontières
est-ce qu'on est le seul pays où c'est
si difficile que ça obtenir un
renouvellement ou un passeport avant un
voyage est ce qu aux etats unis c'est la
même chose en italie en france mais en
france c'est peut-être la fâcher les
lots mais est ce qu'on est le canard
boiteux à ceux sur ce sujet là
et que j'allais pas mal de préceptes en
national s'ils avaient des problèmes à
l'italie ou ailleurs avec des gens qui
cale d'or avec un temps devrait avoir un
passeport ça se saurait ça serait
quelque part aujourd'hui on l'aurait vu
moi je n'ai pas vu entre quoi peut-être
que les journaux veulent pas parler
ok très bien je vous remercie il me
reste le temps de vous remercie
pour ce panel pour tous les autres et
pour tous les prochains alors passer un
bon été messieurs à très bientôt on
n'était pas voir aussi pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne i see her dit